welcome to this video playing and chess
hex chess hex from the US and this is a
new opponent never played him before
okay so hmm can i play Bishop c5 the
house there okay Bishop f7 is not a good
move okay you to be need to still check
those things game let's see hmm that's
interesting can I try to play d5 here
using his somewhat somewhat uncommon way
to develop I think it's interesting if
he takes on d5 I have a choice i can
take on d5 intending night f form I can
play e-form evil is also interesting
yeah before it's very interesting ed 5e
form takes on c6 Bishop g4 for for a
mess but an interesting mass let's check
this you for takes c6 Bishop g-form
maybe d4 I take on f3 do you have I have
rupee 80 that's a ton of development
okay if he goes 95 I have at least a
half Bishop g4 and tending Queenie 195
how interesting and Bishop g4 is of
course also a threat okay um but after
that if I go Bishop g4 what are you
doing with your queen you cannot player
3 this is a pin yeah what exactly did
you calculate
Bishop g4 it's a bit embarrassing why
loses the Queen now yeah there's no
square okay okay he does not lose the
Queen he can give up the night instead
so look II ate here first gaining this
temple yo I guess so quindi one must be
played and now let's think about it
Bishop age three takes on c6
nitey form maybe deform
he for trying to find the meteor come on
there must be a checkmate I cannot
believe it when 95 was very easy when
just taking the piece but i really want
to want to meet him here let's see takes
on c6 94 with Queen g5 mate being the
threat night efore d4
and to Queen h4 mm-hmm
or is there is there something more
convincing I really thought there should
be a median night if for deform it's not
not one hundred percent CLE I am as
weird as it as weird as it is I mean at
least I don't see it our queen G 694 d
for Queen g6 is the move King edge 126
ok ok I that that took one that took a
while yeah if I only had more time I
could do some tactics training 2066 out
and that really took a while
yeah I'm King h1 I just go Queen g6
again King King edge one Queen g6 root g
one night f2 made yeah I don't think
there is there is a defense you can do a
desperado on f7 but this is really just
a check
yeah it took me a while to recognize
that I can also give a check on the
sixth-ranked here with the Queen why a
d6 or queen f6 mmm also while Sam was
the root term to the same thing I
believe
yeah that sets over yeah i think this d5
before an approach was quite interesting
Oh didn't didn't take that into account
just Queen g6 I guess I can take it off
class but maybe just just go here
tending Knight f3 double check
yeah and how do we make now 94 Queen f3
Quincy 6 many moves um but what's it
what's them that's the easiest actually
let's let's go here he writes serious
defense here yeah okay maybe I missed
some some quicker some quicker wins
let's now let's just pick up pick up the
pieces now how do I win good what time
will make the quickest win night f2
something Andrew P one night if I can
actually take that ok let's just take
the bishop let's just take the bishop
threatening this just as well now yeah
probably made it far more complicated
than necessary white resigns yeah let's
let's check let's check this this thing
if you for was was really really good
yeah 95 was certainly possible but
unlikely for it was an interesting idea
the computer ever is not convinced at
all it wants to take and now my idea was
Bishop g-form and this the computer is
not even giving so probably it has a big
problem and chill
yeah this is really good him so much for
the interesting idea this is a flood
winning for what ok so I would have been
in trouble i believe i mean i can i can
play that but that's not really not
really convincing now that's not enough
not at all so if or was what's
interesting but not correct at all I
should just take on d5 yeah this however
of course was was just winning 95 you
are also good you ok with it here the
simplest is probably 95 but I thought
there should be a maid somehow we know
that isn't made Queen f6 even a bit
stronger probably because I can I would
have then just taken this but ok it it
is it is ok how I how I played it just
grabbing things check and here we have
the check checkmate the mate coming um
one little detail is that let's go back
here that here this is not a good idea
because I can take Queen Taoiseach and
after g5 Queen takes you need to get the
piece back 94 leads to an excellent
position for black we've got to the
center for no particular compensation ok
thanks for watching